hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast an emerging role of DNA
damage repair in Huntington's disease
presented by money master a PhD a
professor and he kept Graduate Institute
I'm Judy or Arcola birds and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or you can use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. ray I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you very much Judy for the introduction
and it's a pleasure to be here let me
start with a very broad theme how do
diseases occur and you may already know
that there are genes that sometimes make
one susceptible to certain diseases and
so there's this idea of many variants
many genetic variants in the human
population that have different degrees
of susceptibility or resistance to any
kind of disease it could be metabolic
disorder it could be certain kinds of
cancers or it could be even infectious
disease
some such genes have profound effects
and single genes are sufficient to cause
a disease and these are generally known
as Mendelian variants or mutations in
disease genes that segregate in the
human population as gregor mendel how
genes should segregate then the question
of environments how does environment
influence diseases and they can be
grouped into two classes infectious
agents viruses bacteria protozoa and
many other organisms and then there are
the physical or chemical factors
pollutions of pollutants of various
kinds there could be habit-forming
chemicals tobacco smoke and things like
that however it is not the case that
such factors can be separated very
cleanly into these two classes what I
want to emphasize is that diseases are
the result of complex webs of
interactions among genes infectious
organisms perhaps and physical and
chemical agents pollutants and other
agents in the atmosphere so the emerging
idea is that all diseases are probably
the net result of a large web of
interconnectedness if we look at the
genetic variants that might provide
certain kinds of susceptibility to
diseases there are two models one of
which is rather extreme which is in the
lower right hand corner and let us say
that this human beings have genes a b c
d etc a little over 20,000 of them and
there are many common variants of these
disease genes that are segregating in
the human population and each gene has
a few different variants that together
comprise the gene sets of the variants
together comprise the particular
susceptibility characteristic of any
individual within the population but
there is a more nuanced model which is
on the top left I'll tie a little
hypothesis of diseases or disease
susceptibility is that
well these you know roughly 20,000 of
such genes there are many alleles and
these alleles segregate in the human
population and many of these are
actually heterozygous in any individual
and the protein products or sometimes
there are any products of these various
alleles would interact in complex ways
to develop a susceptibility spectrum
that is more than the sum of each of the
parts so diseases are complex outcomes
of rather complex genetic signatures
that all of us bear within our genomes
we came to this this idea and our and
the rest of the talk will focus on
Huntington's disease from doing
something entirely different my
laboratory has been interested in
understanding the properties of
gene-gene interaction and specifically
how genome-wide interaction networks of
genes are involved in maintaining the
genomes integrity that was that has been
the theme of my work over the past 20
years or so however one of my postdocs
in the lab at that time who has now
moved on their own sheep pasture while
in the lab who was looking at the data
obtained from a model organism there is
nothing to do with human brain directly
and that is baker's yeast she noticed
that a large number of genes that
interacted with DNA
jeans were previously flagged because
some of their homologues were interested
in neurological disorders now the kind
of neurological disorders that were
hinted at by these data had something in
common and that is there were all
progressive diseases all appear to be
defective at least in certain aspects of
protein folding properties or protein
folding machinery and examples are
Alzheimer's Parkinson's pay a host of
neurodegenerative disorders that affect
the cerebellum and certain other parts
of the cerebral cortex as well but
mainly the cerebellum called
spinocerebellar ataxia and there are at
least 30 of them probably more although
there are only a few handful of them are
better understood than others and
ultimately the Huntington's disease
which is a rare disease that afflicted
proximately 18,000 to 20,000 people who
in the United States also a progressive
disease and people suffering from this
disease become afflicted at the prime of
their youth generally but the disease
can also affect very early on the
earliest person who had developed
clinical manifestations of the disease
was only four years old this disease is
a inherited disorder and as this
particular pedigree shows that it is
inherited as a single autosomal dominant
manner and that is how this disease was
first discovered being inherited within
the human population the dominance is
because of a mutation in the gene the
gene Maps on the left end of the human
chromosome for and if you look at the
encoded protein the
protein is pretty complex it has got a
large number of very interesting
features for example a poly glutamine or
poly q repeat near the left end which is
the end terminus of the protein but then
there are also other repeated units for
example a little bit to the right of
poly q there is a poly protein where
poly prolene stretch stretch of amino
acids that are enriched in prolene and
then there is a repeat that is called a
heat repeat which is found in a class of
proteins that that have this particular
resident structure the heat repeat
motive is actually repeated at least
three times that we can recognize and
near the C terminal and the carboxy
terminal and there is also a poly
glutamine polystyrene and and poly
prolene stretch mixture of these three
amino acids the problem is that we do
not fully understand even the normal
function of the protein but we know that
if the gene is mutated in a sense that
the poly glutamine repeat in the end
terminus is enlarged from the normal
range of poly glutamine which is
generally about varies between 15 and 28
29 Duty means if it is enlarged beyond
37 to 38 at least beyond 40 then one
gets diseased and a gene that contains
this repeat is therefore a gene that has
a repeated tri nucleotide sequence CAG
CAG codes for glutamine so there is a
long repeat of CAG CAG CAG like that in
a normal gene approximately 25 average
25 to 28 CAG repeats but then in the
people that are
that suffered from the Huntington's
disease this repeat extends to 40 or
more generally now if you look at the
Huntington's disease gene and here
abbreviated as HTT and a protein by the
way is has a colorful name of Huntington
the gene is divided into 67 exons and
the poly glutamine repeat the poly Q
repeat is only at the in the first exon
so if you look at the protein which has
a complex structure it appears that the
disease is mainly related not
exclusively but mainly related to the
presence of a long stretch of poly
glutamine only encoded within the first
exon however a recent work reported last
year shows that there might be an
abnormal processing of the pre messenger
RNA out of this gene which terminates
either within the second exon or within
the intron or within the within another
place within the within the first intron
there are two sites that can serve as
abnormal transcription termination sites
and there is a claim that this
particular abnormal transcription
termination may be related to the
production of an in terminal fragment of
the normal full-length protein that
contains the CAG repeats expression in
terms of poly glutamine and it is this
abnormal transcript that shorter much
shorter transcript that when translated
into the short fragment of protein that
contains the large stretch of long
stretch of poly gouda mean is the toxic
agent that causes this disease the gene
as shown in this slide is expressed in
nearly all cells in the brain which is
shown in the yellow boxes in the brain
it is expressed very highly especially
in the cortical cells but it is nearly
it is expressed in nearly every tissue
that has been examined the cell line
that shows the pink box way up that
actually is an artificial expression so
we should discount that but other than
that these box plots are represents the
level of the messenger RNA in various
tissues that are labeled below so you
can see that the log ratio of the of the
fold ratio of the mRNA is actually high
in nearly every tissue that's one
examines despite this fact that either
the normal protein or that normal
protein is expressed in every cell with
disease hits only certain small group of
cells within the cerebral cortex and
that is shown in the next slide at the
medium spiny neuron are the first ones
to degenerate in the brain of the
Huntington disease patient and later on
higher cortical cells such as the
cortical pyramidal neurons also begin to
degenerate and this slide is complex
it's it's it summarizes what we
understand about what happens when the
abnormal poly Q containing protein is
expressed in a medium spiny neuron
for example the protein is known to miss
fold and also catalyze miss folding by
abnormally interacting and perhaps
saturating the proteasome complex which
leads to mitochondrial dysfunction that
is supposed to trigger cell death the
protein is also known to go into the
nucleus and interfere with the gene
expression the full-length protein is
not supposed to go into the nucleus
but general only a fragment of it is how
much accumulate within the nucleus and
it is the abnormal protein that is the
protein fragment that contains the high
the long length of the [ __ ] you
repeat seems to be abnormally
interfering with the gene expression of
many genes including certain genes that
are important for neural function such
as pretty rightly retractor and so on
the protein also appears to function
within the synapse and it is it has been
implicated in transmission transport and
translocation of proteins and RNA cargo
along neural filaments now on to the
synaptic terminals and it is thought
that the abnormal protein interferes in
this synaptic transmission as well so
the protein might be doing a whole lot
of different things at least the toxic
protein might be interfering with a
large number of different molecular
processes mitochondrial function for
liaison function
gene expression axonal transport of
materials and reuptake of
neurotransmitters and the axonal
junctions now a lot of people
researchers who are working on
Huntington's disease look at it from
different perspectives and we are like
blind men who are trying to interpret
what we are looking at while touching
various parts of an elephant whereas the
real elephant lies hidden behind behind
high levels of complain so to summarize
it appears that the CAG repeat lengths
within the first exon of Huntington's
disease gene or Huntington gene is very
important within the germline of certain
individuals the CAG repeat length
appears to expand so
their children are born with long tracts
of CAG within the first exon which leads
to expanded Polygram interact within the
huntingtin protein and people with
repeats 36 or less are generally normal
people with CAG repeats of strata length
about 40 or 100% afflicted by the
disease however how early the clinical
manifestation of the disease will
setting depends on how long the tract is
if the tract is short like 27 to 40 the
disease afflicts much later in life on
the other hand if the tract length is
very long about 40 the longer it is the
earlier one gets the disease on average
it is thought that they have normal
Huntington's disease proteins toxic to
the median spine in Ihram but it is also
toxic to a large number of different
cells that have been that have been
looked at especially in model systems
for example yeast the baker's yeast
expressing the wild type Huntington's
protein fragment and terminal fragment
is perfectly normal but the same
internal fragment containing a poly
glutamine repeat in a long poly
glutamine repeat like 40 repeats or
longer the e cells die through early if
the human normal protein of different
kinds of versions are expressed within
the Drosophila I cells which have
partnerin and characteristics the AI
cells
degenerate if the protein is the mutant
protein but the normal hunting
controlling does not affect the AI cells
similarly in the worm C elegans which is
another beautiful model system for
neurobiology if the protein is expressed
in the body wall muscle cells or
in certain neurons if a protein is
normal normal length poly q nothing
happens but if the poly Q stretch is
long then the muscle cells or the
neuronal cells should defect and warm
shows all kinds of phenotypes such as
faster aging sluggishness to touch
response and ability to move around is
made sluggish in other words the worm
also shows various kinds of behavioral
and mechanical phenotypes that normal
phenotypes if you look at human beings
that contain the patients that contain
long expanded poly Q repeats protein
expressed in their in the brain cells
you see that progressively the person
would develop neurological symptoms it
is taught speculated that most likely
the abnormalities in other words the
toxic effects of the proteins setting
pretty early but they're simply
undetectable by the present-day
diagnostic techniques but when the
clinical manifestation occurs it's
probably already too late because the
toxic levels of the protein has already
done damage to the brain cells and
various degrees of clinical
manifestations such as such as very
early signs such as depression clinical
depression and then later motor
impairments cognitive impairment and
dementia followed ultimately by by
paralysis and and Korea which is which
is involuntary movement of the
extremities these things happen and this
is also correlated with changes in the
macroscopic changes in the brain for
example the cortical gray matter size is
depleted over time a cortical white
matter is depleted faster and the
striatal volume also collapses so there
are two models as to how the molecular
pathogenesis occurs one is a simple
protein accumulation model and that
assumes that the rate of progression of
this neurodegenerative disease is
entirely dependent on the mutant
huntingtin accumulation over time so the
longer one waits the more such mutant
protein accumulates if you think that
the poly queue length is constant within
a particular patient let us say a
patient that contains a gene with with
only 50 CAG repeats is going to develop
the disease somewhat late in life let's
say around the middle age around 45 to
55 years of age and that is because the
protein containing approximately 50 few
repeats glutamine repeats is going to
have a tendency to accumulate and that
accumulation tendency is such that
critical clinical symptoms arise around
the Middle Ages or so however a person
bearing let's say T future debates in
other words a poly key of length 80 is
going to have protein accumulation the
toxic protein accumulation in the brain
cells much faster and so this person is
going to have most likely on average
have a much earlier onset of the disease
let's say by twenty four twenty five
years of age or so the second model says
that given that the person is born with
at least one copy of a particular long
repeat length above at or above 40 CAG
there is a tendency in the somatic cells
of the body including in the brain cells
during replication of the pre neuronal
precursors for the somatic expansion of
this CAG repeat in the cells sometimes
the repeat length may contract even but
sometimes it can expand this leads from
the observation that people with
approximately 34 35 36 37 repeats tend
to have children who very often have
much longer repeats sometimes the
children have shorter repeats as well
but they do have children that have
longer repeats so if it can happen in
the germline can it happen in the
somatic cells so a person born with
either a mother or a father usually a
father that can change let's say 40
beats in the germline of the father the
40 repeat Oh
CAG may expand to 60 and then a child
may be born with 60 repeats now it is
possible that this person during the
cell division in embryogenesis and brain
development and then later you know some
some stem cells in the brain can
actually have unstable repeats so the
repeat length may increase even faster
may increase even higher to let's say 70
80 even hundred or more than hundred C
repeats and in these cells the toxic
protein is very highly toxic because it
has got so many T repeats so this model
says that these somatic cell
heterogeneity might predispose the
person to much earlier onset of the
disease then otherwise possible having
only let's say 40 or 50 beats to begin
with so in other words molecule length
of this toxic protein varies among the
neurons and the neurons with longer
repeat lens
we'll be degenerate faster that's the
assumption however let me make it clear
that the two models are not mutually
exclusive and both of these two
processes might be happening to some
extent a recent publication sort of
summarizes these two models together and
explained so that adult-onset repeat
range which is which has shorter
relatively short CAG repeat lengths is
explained by the fact that shorter poly
q proteins might be less toxic than
longer poly key repeats whereas those
people that that have a much earlier
onset of disease such as the juvenile on
set repeat range there much longer
repeats and that could be because the
protein containing longer CAG protein
containing longer poly Q repeats
may be much more highly toxic or perhaps
the repeat instability the somatic
repeat expansion explains the early
onset in such people I have mentioned
that the repeat length is inversely
proportional proportional to the age of
onset but that is an oversimplification
if you look at the real data the data
are sort of messy yes you can find a
line of regression through them but
there is a large large scatter in the
data the variance about 70% of the
variance in the age of onset can be
explained by the length of the Sierra
Peach
however and and this length length of
the CD repeat is only guess that not by
the length of the CAG repeat in the
brain but length of this here you repeat
in the somatic blood cells so it is not
clear whether the length of the CA
repeat in the blood cell it exactly
reflects the length to the somatic of
the CAG repeats in the brain cells
because they could be somatic
recombination in the brain
glass it appears that from this data
that all don't want average it is true
that as the repeat length increases the
age of onset is earlier there are a lot
of exceptions for example somebody which
who may have a clinical symptom very
highly developed at the age of 50 may
have it may have a repeat length varying
from varying from 40 to about 55 or even
60 so there is a lot of variance and
about 33% of the variants cannot be
explained by the repeat length only and
so one begins to think of other
influences such as environmental or even
other genetic factors that are inherited
in human population because of the
variants in the in the in the 20,000
other genes 3,000 or so other genes that
are segregating in the human population
the different alleles that I eliminate
you in the first few slides so this is
diagrammatically explained in this slide
so CAG of length 40 has a much later
onset CAG of length 80 has an earlier
onset and CAG of hundred has a much
earlier onset however if you choose
people with let's say an average
CAG repeat length who who manifests
Huntington's disease say CAG or 50 then
you can imagine that there might be
other alleles of some of the 20,000
other genes which might be good modifier
genes and therefore they could push the
age of onset of clinical manifestation
to a later date or there could be some
other alleles that are bad modifier
genes that could push it to an earlier
onset date so if so
we ought to be able to discover good and
bad modified genes for Huntington's
disease and what could these modified
genes be well the genes
what if our genes could be any of the
genes whose products interact with the
Huntington's disease proving the the
normal or the mutant the normal
Huntington's disease protein is actually
essential for embryonic development
especially for brain development so it
is an important part of brain
development it is not clear whether the
protein plays any blow yourself other
than the brain and in fact evidence
suggests you don't know for sure but at
least it is important for mouse and
human brain development and either
interacting proteins with normal
Huntington's disease praveen or with
abnormal Huntington's disease petrovic
if there are really differences in the
genes encoding suchan's they might be
good or bad more fired up disease so let
us try to look at it instead more detail
so let us say that a mutant protein
somehow produces that part and there is
a modified gene X we did for the mutant
protein to make the toxic if that's
possible so if such a modifier details
so that the gene is lost let's Italy did
we then such mutations would suppress
the Huntington's disease manifestation
because the toxic effects will be milder
because it is not there to help the
mutant huntingtin protein to produce the
toxic effect in other words such
mutations would show up as suppressors
of Huntington's disease phenotype in
model systems for example and in humans
they might certain allelic variations
that would reduce the activity of the
protein can show up as good modifiers of
Huntington's disease
if we can identify such genes
immediately the problem such gene
products could be plausibly therapeutic
candidates because by raising a small
molecule we might be able to inhibit the
activity of the gene excess protein and
thus would basically fee no copy or
rather translate the effect of the
mutation in such gene so we would we
would and make the protein crippled by
by means of a chemical and thus the
mutant huntingtin protein will not be
able to exert its toxic effect there
could be the opposite kind and that is
there could be a modified gene Y which
normally suppresses or inhibits the
mutant huntingtin proteins toxicity and
therefore loss of function mutations of
such modified gene why would take away
such negative influence and therefore
would enhance the toxic effect so the
loss of function mutations in gene why
would enhance Huntington's disease and
he could imagine a gene z which is a
negative regulator of the modified gene
Y will look like the modifier gene acts
and therefore that also can become a
therapy a candidate so now you begin to
see an a picture emerges gene gene being
important in understanding and perhaps
discovering therapeutic candidate
targets for Huntington's disease
treatment as I mentioned before we came
to this problem of Huntington's disease
by studying a completely different
question we were trying to understand
how gene gene interaction Network
maintains the integrity of the genome
and in order to do that we mutate some
essential gene in the organism so the
organism dies and then we manipulate
other genes
the genome so that the organism is
resurrected so to say and one of the
ways we could resurrect the organism by
bypassing the requirement of some
essential gene is by means of rewiring
the gene interaction Network so imagine
a pathway on the left that produces some
gene product X through a series of gene
actions e F and so on and this X pathway
is essential for life now suppose a
mutation occurs in F so that the pathway
X is in operative and as a result the
organism dies what can we do to
resurrect the organism what we found is
that there exists a large number of
either structurally or functionally
redundant genes in the genome that we
can tweak in order to resurrect the
pathway X some of these genes such as G
or H normally do not participate in the
production of X but produces Y which may
or may not be sentient for life however
in the absence of the gene product F we
can perhaps tweak the expression of gene
G which is a structurally redundant gene
for gene F makes a protein that is very
similar but not identical to F so called
paralog as genes may take the function
may take over the function of F and thus
rescue the mutant F so X the pathway X
becomes operative again and thus when
the organism survives we also found a
much larger number of genes of the type
H which have no structural relationship
to any of the genes that well there but
are functionally redundant and they can
be to their expression can be to a tree
concerns so that
they take over the function of the last
function of f and thus resurrect the
organisms through restoring the pathway
X such genes are functionally not
structurally but functionally redundant
and they are called degenerate or
promiscuous they catalyze degenerate or
promiscuous pathways so structural and
functional redundancy appear to be
important for maintaining genomic
integrity however there is a paradox in
here
imagine that one needs to cross a stream
from one side to the other and there are
three bricks or stones on which one can
step on and these three bricks are like
three genes they're essential now
suppose that you put a non-essential
gene like a plank on top of this and now
you can walk over the plank but the
plank is not essential because you can
hop over the you can basically step over
the bricks but if the plank is there it
is possible for the evolution to
actually mutate away one of the three
bricks the one in the center because it
has no function so you can walk over the
plank from one side to the other however
now one of those bricks have become
essential because the span between the
extreme two bricks is very long and if
that brick is taken away also the plank
collapses and as a result you have a non
function of the British and similarly
you have a non function of that way if
an essential gene is removed in other
words if you have genes that are
essential it introduces vulnerability to
the organism in terms of whether the
genes can be mutated and still keep the
organism safe in terms of disease
susceptibility so to speak so this is
the concept that we have been
very interested in for a very long time
and we found such functionally redundant
pathways there are their cryptic
pathways they exist in the genome a
large number of them and they are
responsible for functionally
reconfiguring gene-gene interaction
networks to take care of mutations in
essential genes one such example is
shown here in psyche more detail when a
cell divides there is a trigger that
induces cell division cell cycle begins
and goes through the process of mitosis
ultimately and then mitosis begins at
that point DNA condenses two chromosomes
distinct chromosomes and then the
chromosomes separate to the two daughter
cells this process is dependent on a
particular protein called s mc2 and if
you mutate away the gene for s MC - it
blots that pathway the DNA fails to
condense and as a result the chromosomes
fail to separate the DNA's ripped apart
during the cell division process and a
self-tanner and both of the two cells
die however it looks like it is possible
to bypass this in two entirely different
manner in one manner you can prevent the
DNA to get entangled
even though the DNA fails to condense
and by the second way you do not prevent
the DNA entanglement the DNA fields to
condense they entangle however they can
you can facilitate the DNA
disentanglement by other genes and thus
bypass the the nutritional block of s
and say - and then allow the chromosomes
to separate and the two daughter cells
survive this is the kind of story we
were interested in and barrace in my lab
found that a large proportion of genes
that could bypass the
essentially two block appears to have
been flagged as those somehow involved
in neurological disorders so we went to
use genetics to actually probe this
question are there genes that could
bypass the Huntington's disease gene
toxicity Huntington's disease being a
model of neurodegenerative disorders and
this was started way back in what way 20
years ago by Susan Lindquist who
unfortunately is no longer with us she
had shown that you can you only use the
awesome power of his genetics to
actually probe this so you can look at
the physical interactors interacting
proteins of the wild-type and mutant
Huntington's protein you can use use
genetics to probe such interactions as
genetic suppressors or enhancers of the
wild type or mutant huntingtin protein
activity in yeast and the goal is to
generate hypotheses for future testing
and validation in other organisms so
beyond she did that she expressed the
normal Huntington protein in yeast and
the cells survive he expresses the
mutant huntingtin protein in yeast in
the cells die and now he expresses
candidate suppressor genes in the cells
that Express the mutant huntingtin
protein and asks whether the cell dies
or lives and by this min means he found
a lot number of suppressors and
enhancers of the mutant huntingtin
protein which people did not discover
before and some of these findings led us
to suspect that certain neurotransmitter
metabolism for example keine renin which
appears to be a very important
metabolite in the production of a large
number of small molecule
neurotransmitters in a central nervous
system its metabolism is somehow related
to the integrity
of chromosomal DNA genomic DNA in the
slide is shown a network of the genes
that link the SMC to SMC for condensing
complex to the Kiner and in metabolism
genes be nf5 and B and a for and how the
human Huntington Bab normal purine
somehow interacts with the with the
chromatin review organization complex
sse2 NSSC for to stabilize the
condensing complex and interact with the
human with the yeast genome that somehow
protects the the mutant Huntington's
effect through the Kiner and in
metabolism the proposed connection
between the kind Iranian mono oxygenase
an enzyme required for metabolism of kin
renin and mutant huntingtin protein is
diagonalized here in which we suspect
that BNF for and being a 5 proteins
together make it complex which somehow
interact with the Huntington protein and
the mutant protein interacts in a manner
such that the condensing stabilizing
complex during the mitosis of cells or
during other processes within the cell
for example neuronal cells do not divide
but pre neuronal cells do and the
neuronal cells require condensation of
certain parts of the chromatin in order
to express certain genes such as a
ribosomal DNA and and various other DNA
and these processes may be abnormal
through this particular interaction a
scheme that I'm that we have proposed
here
this slide shows in more details some of
the mechanisms in which other DNA repair
recombination proteins such as rad51 MN
d1 and DMC 1 and we have genetic
evidence for these somehow interact with
a kind of random metabolism involving
mitochondria and how
the Huntington protein is interacting
with the layers of the chromosomes of
chromosome dynamics and DNA repair
recombination to screw up the process of
kinda random metabolism and
mitochondrial function so we wrote a
paper suggesting that genetic modifiers
of Huntington's disease that also
function in maintaining the genome
integrity might be important to
understand the pathophysiology of
Huntington's disease and so we went to
the computer to try to just to
investigate this process so the idea is
that in America rather than in and not
in England you are who your neighbors
are in England you are who you are born
from so in America because you are who
your neighbors are you look at the
proteins that interact with each other
and by looking at the identity of the
proteins in such protein-protein
interaction network and knowing some of
their functions you can the complexes
may betray the function of the unknown
proteins so this is what my PhD student
Sonali tried to do
she is a medically qualified person she
has an MD but she came to my lab to do
computational biology so what she did is
took the gene gene interaction data that
we generated took genome-wide loss of
function suppressor screams in yeast for
mutant huntingtin protein to accessory
of various sets some done in 2005 some
done in 2003 and then we did a separate
work by in 2003 in which we found other
suppressors of the Huntington's toxicity
and then she combined these data of
gene-gene interaction with datasets
of protein-protein interaction obtained
by mass spectrometry of core
immunoprecipitated proteins from mouse
brain so she took the genetic
interaction data from yeast took the
protein protein physical interaction
data from mouse spray and then put them
together in some clothes clever ways and
then mapped them to the human protein
protein interaction which is deposited
in the hippie database and found a large
network of interactions which she called
the Huntington's disease integral 16% of
the total protein protein interaction in
the human interaction mapped onto this
Huntington's protein interacting so are
the Huntington protein interaction
partners in the human inferred
interaction diagram network do they
imply related function so how do you ask
such a question so what you do is a
series of machine learning you apply in
series of machine learning algorithms
and one of them this is a class of
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
so called clustering which captures
overlapping functional relationships
among genes and proteins in the network
so imagine two genes one and two are
they related well they would be related
if the product of gene one interacts
with let's say some other proteins f1 f2
and f3 and f4 and the product of gene
two interacts with f5 f6 f7 and f3 so if
two genes share one interactor they're
related by function so this is what I
meant by you are who your neighbors are
so using an algorithm called cluster 1
which looks at protein-protein
network based on some cohesiveness
measure which I will not go into this
the the technical details of it she ran
it under logic that the yeast genes gene
interaction somehow has an evolutionary
relationship to the mouse protein
protein interaction which has an
evolutionary relationship with the human
protein protein interaction and such
relationships have precise physical
meaning for example if gene one
interacts with gene two then it may be
that product of gene one may actually
regulate the expression of gene - or the
product of gene one and gene to
physically interact with each other to
make something meaningful or maybe a
combination of these two models so she
applied such clustering algorithms on to
the integrated interact among
Huntington's disease integral which
looks like a big mess of spaghetti
however machine learning unsupervised
machine learning which allows people to
do clustering of clusters of network
members on the basis of some hidden
properties that are not very apparent in
the beginning allows one to discover
meaningful associations but there is
also another method called supervised
learning which is able to classify the
mechanisms of such hidden rules within
the spaghetti of interact Holmes and I
will discuss that
let us concentrate on the unsupervised
learning first in which the
protein-protein interaction is
classified based on connectivity and
density functions which led to several
very statistically pious intent clusters
and some of the top clusters had
proteins that were enriched for
functions of DNA damage DNA repair and
chromosome organization this was
surprising because we did not start with
any hypotheses about what the cluster
the neighbor neighbor neighboring
functions would actually imply we simply
took the entire data sets and ran the
clustering found the statistically most
significant clusters and lo and behold
what came out our DNA repair function
again another DNA repair function so
this is not a fluke of the clustering
method because SM clustering method also
gave rise to essentially similar results
and I will not go into the detail of
this so having run this clustering
algorithms and having found this protein
clusters that may have something to do
with DNA repair recombination in
interactions with a mutant Huntington's
protein we wanted to see how far this
method can be generalizable by trying to
validate the candidates of the clusters
on other in other model organisms so we
went to Joseph Allen and took the first
you know twenty to twenty-five genes of
which we have so far been able to test
only about ten and out of this one two
three four five six seven candidate
genes out of ten have turned out to be
actual modifiers of mutant huntingtin
protein on the Drosophila eye phenotype
for example NP lack for ESP l1 n a PC
seven and so on in LRC for all of these
genes either the loss of function of
these genes or the gain of function of
these genes either enhance or suppress
the effects of the mutant huntingtin
protein stop for a second and think
about what we did
we took genetic interaction data which
which suppressed mutant huntingtin
toxicity in yeast combined them with a
host of mouse brain data in which the
mutant huntingtin protein was core
immunoprecipitated and by mass
spectrometry asked what other proteins
came with it
combine them using evolutionary criteria
and mapped them on the human protein
protein interaction interaction
clustered them to find what functions
there are the top functions had
something to do with DNA repair
recombination we took those human genes
found they're just a filler orthologs
and then mutated or overexpress some of
these genes and lo and behold what we
find is that at a very high frequency
seven out of ten we find genes that
express some modifier function for the
mutant Huntington's toxicity very
interestingly as we were doing this
experiment we came across a paper
published in self back in 2015 and when
we when we did this work the paper was
not published yet it did a genome-wide
Association meta-analysis of few
thousand protein there were people in
Europe and America combined try to see
whether there are variations and on
human population in other genes that
might provide a clue to modifier low
sigh within for Huntington's disease
patients age of onset phenotype and
reported that there is one gene that
they found to have a high signal this
gene was called fancy fanc CI Francona's
anemia complex group one this gene was
previously known to be a Mendelian
disease gene for Fanconi anemia which is
a which is a disease of the blood
circular system of the connective tissue
hematological disease but its gene seems
to some alleles of this gene appeared to
be a modifier of the Huntington's
disease age of onset phenotype the gene
was known already to have something to
do with handling of the DNA repair
process and and that seems seems to have
something to do with the modification
well both the Fanconi anemia and
modification of the propensity for
getting early onset Huntington's disease
in humans it was also shown to be a
modifier of spinocerebellar ataxia of a
certain kind so it looks like we have
hit a jackpot that already in our
candidate which we haven't tested yet in
any other organism there is a human gene
that has been reported from a large
genome-wide Association meta-analysis to
be a modifier of Huntington's disease so
let's go to the second methods
supervised learning so it's supervised
learning one takes a Royal interaction
data and then manipulates that to make
it scales data and divides them into two
sets a so-called training set and a
validation set the training set is used
to instruct a model that we supply and
the computer the machine learns from
this training set some hidden
Association within the data and then
spits out a model a trained model which
we validate using the validation set and
then using a completely new data ask
what is the how efficiency how
efficiently the model is validation
validated so we get a profit you can
easily imagine where we got this picture
from from the internet from from finance
companies but actually we are not in the
business of making money for us the
profit is the genes dyj entity of the
genes that provide
the hidden relationship with the mutant
huntingtin spear means modifier so
sonali ran a host of such supervised
machine learning algorithms and explored
their their their ability to classify
the data and to to simplify and the long
make the long story short she found one
that actually predicted with very high
efficiency over 85% efficiency new
interactions that the machine did not
know before and I'm going to go through
this very quickly so we had to supply
the model so what model so we said that
certain features are the protein-protein
interaction network in the in the
Huntington's disease interaction
obscures geometrical models mathematical
models of the network these are features
in the learning parameters as well as
protein domains and motives as it turns
out so what doing explain the next
paragraph in the next slide that the
data are of three types the training
sets are of three types proteins that
interact with the wild-type Huntington
protein proteins that interact with a
mutant huntingtin protein only and
proteins that interact with both
wild-type in the mutant huntingtin
protein and using these three data sets
can we instruct the machine to learn
something about it so that they can
classify new protein in these three
groups geometrical properties and
preened structural properties that we
used protein motifs protein domains
there are 996 motifs in 673 mines and
then a series of abstract geometric
properties being protein interaction
Network and I will not go into the
definitions of these but suffice it to
say that what we what she found is a
domains protein domains were not at all
instructive it is somehow the protein
motifs but mainly that ab struggle prop
is geometrical properties or the
protein-protein
action such as between the centrality
closeness centrality and things like
that
they were the most important parameters
to train the machine to be successful
this is how the input data look like I'm
for the gravity of time and I will not
go into this among the various models
machine learning models that she used
only the GBM or gradient boosting model
was more efficient than others and
ultimately the GBM results show that one
in the center is that area under the
curve of 0.85 on unknown data which
basically is a pretty high accuracy of
predicting novel interactors of mutant
huntingtin protein the interesting thing
about supervised machine classification
is that it can also regress which means
it can think backwards or compute
backwards to find the modified genes
themselves so what did we learn we
learned a hostile modifier genes which
are listed here too small I suppose in
this slide but I will not go into it
this detail one by one but most of these
genes have something to do with already
known human neurological desert
disorders stop for a second and think
about what we did now we imagined that
there are some hidden properties of
proteins that interact with a mutant
huntingtin protein and trained computer
algorithms to search for such properties
and once the machine was trained it
could identify such features and told us
a set of proteins or genes that should
with high probability interact only with
the mutant huntingtin peering and lo and
behold some of these genes are already
known to be involved in certain
progressive human neurological disorders
not Huntington's disease but other
neurological disorders such as
spinocerebellar ataxia and certain other
diseases
so we are now taking this one system to
another organism
taking these inferences to another model
organism and that is the senior reptiles
elegance which has exactly 302 neurons
comparative just Hoffler for example who
which has some 250,000 of them so it's a
much more tractable organism and as the
diagram below shows that that majority
of the neural connections are already
configured for this for this organism so
we can begin to ask a very precise
questions about whether some of these
genes actually modify the Huntington's
disease praveen's toxicity in the worm
in their nervous system and we are
collaborating with Paul Sternberg at
Caltech to do this work now last January
craig Venter and his co-workers
published a paper in nature review of
genetics where they scanned thousands of
tens of thousands of genomes and in
vitro experiments for genes that are
essential for human survival and came up
with a core set of 188 essential human
genes and they showed a gene gene
interaction map of this 188 essential
human genes amazingly many of our
candidate modifier genes of Huntington's
disease protein map wanted these onto
this particular 188 essential human core
essential human gene interaction map
they have shown Craig Venters craig
Venter and his co-workers have shown
that there is a very high likelihood
that mutations in one or more of these
188 genes occur in people with with
diseases genetic disorders as this
diagram taken from their paper suggests
so the pathogenic variants of essential
human genes at a very high frequency
predisposed the human population to
certain genetic disorders and we have
shown that the computationally
identified set of modifier genes are
highly enriched in terms of their
membership within the one hundred and
eighty eight core essential human genes
so the question at last is does the
robustness property of the genome make
us intrinsically vulnerable to diseases
the genomes are there presumably for the
selfish reason for the genome to be
propagated and therefore there are
reconfigurable networks that have been
selected in evolution but the other part
of this is that such reconfigurable
networks may have made the hosts of such
genomes in other words us vulnerable to
diseases the genomes are selfish they
don't care but as a result we become
vulnerable to genetic disorders however
can we exploit this very vulnerability
to find cures for diseases such as the
modifier X that I had mentioned few
slides back which could be a drug target
and that is the intent of our future
work so from a fundamental question
which is the basis of Reverse of gene
interaction Network we did some
experiments using serendipitous us found
a by chance a disease connection with
the idea that networks embody
information we learn the hidden
knowledge in large data sets and we let
computing machines learn from the data
with model organisms we are evaluating
whether the machines are learning well
and would the fruits of the machine
learning make biological hypothesis
about the disease testable in the future
and perhaps give us leads for
discovering
novel therapies so in the closing let me
acknowledge the work of Bianchi Parra
who has since moved on Jessie a previous
graduate student a PhD student who had
also moved on
sonali also moved on katerina vendor
over my colleague and her laboratory and
Roddick in K Graduate Institute School
of Pharmacy who have done all the fly
work dr. sangjun KU who is a
collaborator he's an applied
mathematician Paul Stromberg and Celtic
with whom we are now collaborating using
the worm system and innumerable KGI
students including undergraduate
students from outside who have worked in
my lab over the past 14 years thank you
very much
so we can now have questions for the
questions if you have any Thank You dr.
ray for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is which of the two models
cumulative aggregation of one poly
glutamine length protein or somatic
instability of the repeats explains the
computational findings that's a pretty
good question unfortunately we don't
know the answer to that but let me try
to explain some implications of that so
DNA repair recombination processes not
only repair damages to the DNA they're
also known to actually expect or
participate in the processes that expand
and contract repeat a DNA there are
decades of work on that so the fact that
modifiers of mutant
and protein are sometimes participants
in DNA repair and recombination can work
in quite a way in one way
somatic recombination might be enhanced
such that long repeats can be produced
from shorter repeats and as a result bad
modified modified by our effect actuated
or the recombination enhancement can be
shortened can can contract therapy
length and so good repair function can
be actuated on the other hand entirely
differently cebú that the toxic effects
of Huntington protein somehow manages to
damage the DNA this is hinted at but
branches work which shows that DNA
chromosome proteins physically interact
with the mutant engine protein so the
mutant hunt probably made a fear with
the Comics DNA d condensation and
condensation process they lead to
entanglement of the chromosome of the
DNA and thus interfere with gene
expression in neural cells and as a
result genomes within the neural cells
might collapse my disintegrate and
perhaps some it so happening so the
computational work is agnostic in terms
of what mechanism by which these
modifiers are acting so now the time has
come to painfully address these
questions one by one to find the actual
molecular mechanisms by which the mutant
huntingtin protein interacts with a deal
with with the DNA damage repair system
and whether it's the model one and model
two or perhaps a combination the two
well thank you we have time for one more
question
why should this machine learning
approach be fruitful it can only learn
from the data that already exists
so where is the novelty right so the
novelty is in the sense that the machine
learning algorithms can only work on
very large data sets that no human being
can actually make sense off
moreover traditional statistical methods
of linear regression or logistic
regression can only look at linear
correlations for example if a is
correlated with b and b is correlated
with c we can say that a is correlated
with c so these this is a case of linear
correlation but machine learning can
find things that are perhaps non
linearly correlated we simply don't
understand what it is because the
mathematics of it has not yet been
developed there may be nonlinear
relationships hiding in large amounts of
data and we do not have direct logical
methods of analyzing them which only
some hidden properties of the machine
learning algorithms can can find in
other words supervised machine learning
is able to find relationships where
individual parts combine together to
make something that is more than the sum
of the individual parts and that's where
the potential for such work lies it is
not that the data are novel the data are
not novel but by analyzing the data we
get model insights and that is the
novelty of the sort well I would like to
once again thank dr. ray for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab ruth's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 15 to
2018 you will receive an email
labyrinths letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye